though seems to be coming out of nowhere
funny story behind this before I get to
the intro I was going to inner geek the
movie trivia Schmo down between me and
Robert Myer Burnett did pretty well for
myself except the Harry Potter questions
I got murdered in the Harry Potter
questions like what the hell's wrong
with me I know Harry fund would not wait
no I read those books ten years ago a
decade does fly by I didn't keep up on
that [ __ ] it got rusty it sucks so as
I'm rewatching the Harry Potter movies
to give that memory CPR I figured I well
since I'm watching them I might as well
review them maybe it's not the best
timing I probably could have waited for
a more Wizarding World centric timeframe
like when the next fantastic beast movie
comes out of whatever but that is not
how I roll I have reviewed the Deathly
Hallows Part 1 and 2 on my channel as
they came out so this will be first one
through half-blood Prince I'll put a
link below to the movie trivia modown so
you can watch it maybe like it give me
some support so that's the story so
let's talk some Harry Potter
[Music]
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone or
Philosopher's Stone depending on where
you live in our muggle world so Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone slash
Philosopher's Stone is the first movie
in the Harry Potter franchise the first
one adapted from the book this arts that
little Harry Potter turns 11 years old
he lives with his aunt and uncle life
really sucks they make him sleep under
the stairs this is not the life anyone
want to live which is why we're rooting
for Ben Hagrid from Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry comes in because
you're a wizard Harry come with me let's
learn some magic at Hogwarts now he goes
misses his first year at Hogwarts any
meets his friends Hermione Granger Ron
Weasley that we really see we see the
genesis of that which we know the end
game too and we so thoroughly loved so
this is the world-building moment for
Harry Potter and I gotta say I love this
movie more watching it now than I did
when I watched it movie theater I mean I
thoroughly enjoyed it movie theaters
thought it was sweet if I was endearing
but watching it now this setup is so
enjoyable to see because you know where
this is going to go you know what that
means and that Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone is one of those rare
stories that just gets better through
time maybe it's better because I'm
watching it through adult eyes and I can
appreciate it more for what it is maybe
it's better because I've seen the story
wrap up so I really appreciate all the
setup they're doing either case it's a
rarity to see a movie aged as well as
this one does by age well I don't mean
the special effects and the visual
effects age well there is some CGI in
this movie among yep that is 16 year old
CGI a Quidditch match alike that's dated
it's fun as hell it really is but it's
dated
couldn't help but notice them I'm like
that's right at Hogwarts they used to
play Quidditch in this Sun they used to
be nice weather when they played
Quidditch soon as the movies went on
it's like not just dingy cloudy rainy
weather and an interesting game with
interesting rules one little thing that
just breaks the game and wins it for the
other team snitches get stitches that's
what I'm saying as well as some of the
green screaming some of the green screen
you look at you're like that great green
and I can really tell it does make you
appreciate how movies these days have
refined to the art of green screen
whereas Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone came out in a time
where they were like we can use a lot of
green screen because we've totally
mastered that it's like Adam mm it's
funny because I actually humored in my
head I'm like the Quidditch match would
I be okay if they just refined the CGI
keep the cinematography and everything
the same but refined the CGI but that's
just a slippery slope I just leave it as
it is it doesn't break the movie or
anything like that like you're like I
have
good time but now it sells like a really
endearing sweet fun family movie and
it's good Lord building to at the
moments where the movie winds down it's
informative they're talking about spells
and wands just a wand lures fascinating
the spells are fascinating I remember
the first scene in this movie I was like
paper head on broom what a cliche for
witches but they do it in this movie the
way that you're like actively but it
works I mean we're going to live in a
Witchcraft and Wizardry world you might
as well just live it up with brooms and
the great Richard Harris plays Albus
Dumbledore in this Harry Potter
he was Dumbledore he sadly passed away
and they had to recast those
Dumbledore's are great for very
different reasons but they both did a
fine job but this can we give a slow
clap for the casting of Alan Rickman as
Severus Snape was there in is there a
better person who could have ever played
that role and again with the nuance this
is a movie that's like that's the
villain that's the bad guy when Yuri
watch it you see it from a different
perspective and re watching the entire
saga in second time you see Snape
through different spectrums Snape is the
most layered character in this entire
Harry Potter saga I just love the kids
in this movie this is a story where you
know the adults don't really listen to
the kids so the kids got to go out and
do it on their own
putting yourselves in extreme harm's way
in a school it's just not up to code
there are so many things that can kill
kids it's like the teachers like we know
don't go to the Forbidden Forest
or no fences or not' there's nothing
keeping you out we're just saying don't
go because you'll probably die the kids
go on their adventure and they're the
ones who have to save the day - just
some so clear about that everybody
watching this video was a kid at one
time and you know what that's like so
this movie on some level will speak to
100% of the people watching this video
correcta the kids are not refined yet
acting watch some of the lines you like
yeah you got a ways to go again I feel
like I'm being lenient on there because
I know where they end up and none of
them or the kid from Luber I could say
that and the reveal at the end with
Voldemort and what he is right now
it's really fascinating again you should
really read the books because it really
explains what happened with Voldemort
how he is on the back of the head in
fact with a lot of these stories there's
something about the book lore that
you're like this is so much different
the movie just didn't cover everything I
remember that from 10 years ago anyway
the feeling never leaves you the details
sure they may leave you but that feeling
of like that's something special and I
read that never leaves you guys in the
end Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone / Philosopher's Stone was
fantastic
that was perfectly enjoyable for me when
it came out and is even better now that
I've gotten older or now that the saga
has rocked out probably has to do with
both of those events it's wonderful
world building it's super charming it's
magical okay that is it pun intended but
it's the only word I could really use to
describe it it is a magical story even
the appreciation of the fact that this
movie was filmed with 35 millimeter film
I like that the colors are super fresh
they're vibrant you see a little bit
just ever so slightly the sprocket Bob
because of the film I'm not saying it's
a positive or negative I'm just saying
personally for me that's rocket Bob kind
of tipping back I was like oh Phil when
Hagrid and Harry are walking through
Hogsmeade you look at it you're like
this is a movie that looks like it's
about 16 years old holy crap I sound
like an old ass man
but it takes me now I get what my
parents were talking about that stuff
like yeah make like nine years to your
am now I'm that guy guys I'm just saying
I love Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone and it is awesome tacular which is
great because the Harry Potter saga
starts out great ends with a bang I'll
review the ones in-between as we go yeah
yeah that's me saying I'm going to
reveal the Harry Potter film there's no
Harry Potter centric movies out there no
reason for people to search this
whatsoever zap you could spread it
around to be great alright guys so Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone or
Philosopher's Stone have you seen it
what did you think about it do you feel
it holds up for you do you feel it's
gotten better over time dated over time
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]